when I was babysitting one time I was
babysitting and there was a clock like
that but wooden it was a huge wooden
clock yeah my grandma I was watching
there hung a [ __ ] movie and the
weirdest thing first of all I shouldn't
have been babysitting but they knew me
they knew my family and the kids that
were already in bed they just needed
somebody to be down there in case the
house column just don't let him die I
didn't even meet the kids [ __ ] I'm
down there in this huge house in
Connecticut I was a young man in
Connecticut and it's one of those houses
that was built probably at the turn of
the century like Christmas labeling yeah
you know you step an eery and the the
weird thing was that the father I never
forget just a tall kind of severe
looking man said if if you would
restrict yourself to the kitchen and to
the study we would appreciate it
no okay I'm gonna go through your [ __ ]
yeah so there's this [ __ ] grinning
clown a giant grinning clown next to the
clock I mean and it's as its life size
it's a little cinnamon being and it had
it was grinning and it was very scary
look like an old carnival clown nice and
it was not it was like with legs and it
was just all it was just like it looked
real and and and I remember looking at
it going whoever bought that probably
spent a ten thousand dollars on it
because it's it's the detail an artist's
sketch it it looks so [ __ ] real so I
am freaking out over this crowd
I'm not buggin um in that glass eyes I'm
watching the TV and I go I don't want
this thing to be looking at me so I took
the cover from the couch and I put it
over the clown's head and I was like
this is more scary why no that was even
scarier because now I got just the
things legs and it's covered so I'm like
this is freaky man so I go but I'm not
gonna be a [ __ ] I'm gonna watch TV so I
go to the kitchen and one
the kids comes down and says I have a
headache so I go okay I give him some
water and I walk him up back upstairs
put him in bed and I called the dad you
know and I called the mom I called that
and and I said they were actually by the
way this is before cell phones so they
were at a club so I called the club
father gets on and I said I just so you
know Peter has a headache I gave him
some water I just want to let you know
that and oh by the way I put a freaking
blanket over the flowers bloom and he
said what clown you're making this I
went the great clown show to make this
story good means it goes we don't have a
clown take the kids get robbed here you
know I've been seeing clown their dreams
every night into the study there was
just a shilling ground the clown is not
there anymore I grabbed your children at
what point did you bill that's stupid
cuz I was like man this is getting weird
where is he going with this unless
something was really haunted the cloud
go there was in luckily I will kicked it
I knew I killed it I knew you guys see
Ronda Rousey's performance no I didn't
see it but I like the like a lot of the
below-the-belt production team a lot of
the the shoulder and those guys they're
so into Wrestlemania and online the
ratings have been I guess she killed it
she supposedly did really really well
and then after that I assumed it
interview going you know what I'm
actually happy about my UFC losses cuz
it led me to here it's actually for the
better good
so she's alright that's the best-case
scenario yeah that's her carrying Triple
H I saw a highlight of it looks like
she's doing really well
Triple H is a big boy isn't he yes yeah
apparently she hit a home run I don't
know I'll note that more pressing world
but apparently shoot her for her yeah
good for her Lesnar so he signed a deal
with W here II signed with WWE but
there's a clause saying he had one fight
in the UFC this was saying on below the
stay while filming this one of our
topics and I said everyone's freaking
out oh but they need a bra Crocs done
well well no you can do both it's not
exclusive deal so to have one giant
fight
I'm hoping it's John Jones I'd be an
interesting fight huh I think I think
for Brock it's either John Jones could
be a terrible matchup for him so I don't
know if Brock would do why Robert just
get in his face there's a fire John
would just take him down and beat the
[ __ ] out of him take him down
yeah thinking that really yep taking
that heats keep distance for a long time
and pick them apart on the feet and then
take him down trouble yeah but so I
don't think Brockton take that fight I
see Brock versus Francis and got it
that's an interesting things they swing
for the fences but then Brock would just
tackle them get him on the ground
yeah but it's this big kind of you know
can Brock get them down
can frets land a punch you know whoever
does the lanes first it's over as far as
if there's takedown each group if Brock
gets hit he screwed
yeah you could that post would be sick
yeah they're good fight for Brock you
know so it's as almost a saber fight to
mark hunt Brock was Marco that's to talk
about a Viking
well cut as good you know takedown
defense and it's you know a very
experienced Francis she's the show us
Brock Lesnar in high school wrestling
look at how big he was there it's
exactly the same yeah
[Music]
so when the biggest freaks of our life
that man you could barely see there is
look at that neck kids right Jesus bro
good no I like it I mean college college
is stupid now in college
what's that called Shawn yeah that's
called she got lazy look at him
people yes she got beat by that that
Neil Dave never played football zyk you
know what let me go be the starting left
guard for the New England Patriots and
he did it
I'm a Brock fan man I'm not found that
hair cap on broadband you
really innocent high school thick as
strong as it gets I've kind of forgot
about your Invisalign how's it feeling
let me see your teeth it's coming
together are they or are they they're
not really coming together doing nothing
my second tray bro give it give it some
time did they start tighten it up as it
past the professor's apparently you know
you know it's working cuz it's doing but
what if they got it resulting what if
they got it wrong we'll know soon I got
this is my second tray I got I've only
got 12 more to go go go go you wear a
monthly program every week you changed
every 10 days if you go in can't wait
for it to be done really but I do like
chewing on my on the rubber when it let
us skip in there's there's nitrous
appears don't straighten your teeth
veneers just make your teeth white and
my teeth are pretty white yeah and what
[ __ ] world no teeth white listen
don't go on your teeth toy pull back
your head don't go like you acted like
you just saw like a bunch of decapitated
heads don't go like that don't ever do
that again
in my teeth are and people if it
destroys you my stand a bit go let me
see your teeth bro and I gotta know if
they're not that bad cuz I right now
brother job is a bad person your teeth
are 50 shades of yellow